so I dropped my iPhone
so in this clip Sarah was talking about
how she had just dropped her phone in
the forest playing laser tag I dropped
this in the forest playing laser tag
we're here at camera cam since a ton of
creators here there's so many fun
activities we've been having so much fun
so the fact that she first started with
talking about how she dropped her phone
had to use Find My iPhone and it was
like under grass I must have lost it
when I was running then BOOM
miracle of miracles
it took some slow fees and then she
decided to take a slow fee as well and
in this slow fee I was like this will be
great oh and then I'm running behind you
will do like a baby wash I'll just be
chasing a little did I know that I was
wearing and these Lululemon leggings the
head just will not hold a phone in your
pocket if you are running full speed and
not only did I have one phone but I had
two phones
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean it's just like a small little
scuff and honestly I think I could
probably like hmm I mean it survived the
concrete it didn't shatter I haven't
even had it for 15 minute now explain
the slope I can't believe it
no I'm going to believe it yeah I
thought you guys would enjoy this
because I feel like most of the iJustine
memes or any time I have anything most
of the comments are like I dropped my
insert whatever it was that I was
talking about here anyway this is a
short little video I've posted so many
iPhone 11 videos I hope that you guys
have enjoyed them and they'll probably
have a few more coming up soon but in
the meantime I'm gonna finish up editing
this video and finish up that bigger
youtuber roundup so look for that very
soon all right
I'll see you guys later
[Music]